martin biron michel si roger michel
david bonsoir bonsoir
la bonne nouvelle c'est que ça
s'accélère la vaccination qu'on va vous
faire entendre monsieur legault qui
parle de sport mais qui a été agacé de
voir des élus participent à la marche de
dimanche qui réclame l'ouverture des
supports du groupe etc
mais je vais ouvrir une quand même une
parenthèse avec le témoignage de notre
collègue josée elle a écrit là dessus à
plusieurs reprises d'autres l'ont fait
david gendt il y avait des témoignages
de parents
il s'agit de jeunes et moins jeunes aux
prises avec une déficience
intellectuelle ou du jeune autiste qui
n'ont pas le droit actuellement que dans
la liste de priorités sont 8e
donc ce sera selon leur âge la soeur de
josé à 58 ans josé à 60 ans josé va être
vaccinés avant sa soeur alors que sa
soeur si elles étaient vaccinées
pourraient avoir rac sais si je puis
dire à des formes d'activités seraient
moins et peu raide allait marcher dans
les parcs apparaît une vie quoi martin
bureau on n'a demandé aucune aide parce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure on va
demander aux mineurs et on nous dit
c'est pas de ministres qui décident de
l'ordre de la vaccination
il a réseau a en théorie mais si le
ministre veut changer ça ils pourraient
non ben oui quand même un gros pouvoir
d'influencé
disons le la façon dont l'opération
vaccination et c'est certain que ce
genre de témoignage la vente va laisser
des marques là avec le temps là c'est
sûr que l'on langues
on engage l'opération vaccination ça va
ça pourrait aller plus vite ans et on
vaccine pas encore les personnes de 85
ans et plus par exemple au
saguenay-lac-saint-jean ou en
abitibi-témiscamingue alors on va
engager la vaccination pour les
personnes plus âgées vulnérables
mais après c'est vrai qu'il faudra y
avoir une réflexion parce que il ya des
gens qui ont 60 ans qui pète le feu et
en a qui ont 40 2 1 qui sont très
malades et qui aurait besoin ce vaccin
là alors peut-être qu'effectivement il
faudra réfléchir à une façon de faire
passer avant les gens qui sont plus
vulnérables
des histoires qui crève le coeur michel
chassang que vous en pensez vous avez
dit tout à l'heure et vous aviez très
raison il n'ya pas tant de monde que ça
qui serait sur cette liste-là maintenant
qu'il ya plus de l'axé qui a mis
maintenant qu'on sait loc pro pendant
quelques jours même là c'est peut-être
le table commencé à faire des exceptions
je peux comprendre qu'au début 84 mais
là on peut commencer
non seulement à faire des exceptions va
avoir un peu de coeur aussi parce que ya
des situations qui sont quatre hier je
pense que ça soude josé et est assez
clair avec sa soeur il y à des
situations comme celle-là hier de
potasse au sco des millions de personnes
et ça se contrôle à cibler alors il n'y
a pas de secret
et ce n'est pas que josé la légion
présidentiel d'abidjan télé avec ses
parents il y en a plusieurs les
associations qui dit il ya des
situations intenables peut pas envoyer
quelqu'un dans une résidence il va être
enfermé dans sa chambre 14 jours et
michel david
écoutez depuis le début de la pandémie
on improvise continuellement tous les
plans ont été bouleversés l'à peu près
chaque semaine alors je vois absolument
pas pourquoi on changerait pas un peu le
plan de vaccination pour donner priorité
aux gens qui de toute évidence la
subissent une détresse plus grande que
d'autres voilà et est d'autant plus que
maintenant avec les nouveaux vaccins qui
sont beaucoup plus mobile su peut dire
ça serait pas de grosse affaire alors je
serais très surpris qu'à la suite de
cette entrevue l'aller les choses ne
changent pas en tout cas on serait
ministre
on ne sent vous dirai pouvoir en
laissant 12 heures s'il vous plaît il ya
des gens l'autre bas mais comme le dit
si justement michel roger au début on
comprenait parce qu'au début la bien sur
pied mais l'on voit que ça va quand même
relativement rondement oui à des régions
il ya des gens qui nous écrivent
rimouski ailleurs je dise ça va pas
assez vite à notre goût bien sûr mais la
priorité seulement aller vite ça va
aller vite quand ça va commencer et là
où pourrait on a de l'espace vous faire
ce qu'on il ya des gens qui trouvent ça
va pas se mettre dans l'ouverture des
sports on l'a vu
dimanche avec cette manifestation et ça
comme piqué est ce que c'est ça ou
d'autres choses montre que ça entre eux
qui ont piqué un peu le premier mineur
il ya vu des élus à cette marche le chef
du parti québécois entre autres si je ne
m'abuse
je cherche les images leur combat on va
le voir et d'autre je vous fais entendre
monsieur legault cet après-midi pour
vous l'ida dans notre société ont une
responsabilité peuvent pas aller dire là
je compte seuls les restrictions du
sport je compte sur le fait que ce volet
3 4 5 sont une journée sur deux sidi
sosso dit que son compte la science on
compte la santé publié aujourd'hui la
santé publique est pas prêt à ce qu'on
aille plus loin dans l'espoir que ma
chouette que tous nos leaders incluant i
c'est l'assemblée nationale soit
solidaire soit responsable
puis appuie la science appuie la santé
publique la marque
je vois pas un chef allait marcher avec
l'armée autre chose que ce que nous ont
dit appuyer par la science
c'est ce que monsieur legault souffle le
chaud et le froid
parce que des fois il dit c'est moi qui
décide et je vais plus loin que la santé
publique mais l'oeil dans une situation
où il dit c'est la santé publique qui
décide et ce qu'on dit c'est que
beaucoup de frictions entre le
gouvernement et la santé publique
concernant spécifiquement le sport et ça
fait longtemps que ça dure
cette manifestation la scène assez belle
manifestation organisée par un jeune de
secondaire 5 qui avait mobilisé ses amis
qui avait mobilisé ses parents des
représentants de fédérations alors tout
le monde dans la bonne humeur disais moi
je veux faire du sport et il est tous
les partis d'opposition étaient
représentées ans a piqué monsieur
legault vif et encore aujourd'hui au
moment où on se parle
la décision sur ce qui va être annoncé
vendredi et les peaux prison sais pas
quel type de danon son va fermer sa à
challes monsieur legault et on a senti
je pense lui
duke a pleinement heures de son
ascension maudit michel david quand il
veut pas avoir l'air de celui qui
retient les chevaux parce que lui dit
j'aime le sport depuis début mai il dit
je vois des chefs de positionner la
salle lachal elle se lâche aller mais je
comprends que monsieur legault est
fatigué le apprennent à mais depuis
qu'un là on n'a pas le droit de
contester les décisions du gouvernement
et à plus forte raison des élus dont
c'est le rôle de faire la gueule disons
de surveiller et de critiquer au besoin
les décisions qui sont prises par le
gouvernement
et quand monsieur legault dit il faut un
soldat à faux soldats du gouvernement m
il ya quelque chose d'incongru là dedans
quand je l'entends dire ils sont contre
la science écouter et la santé publique
monsieur legault a passé son temps on
l'a vu avec les avis à prendre des
décisions qui étaient possède la santé
publique alors sais pas pourquoi lui
serait le seul à avoir le droit de
déroger chasser comment j'aurais réagi
parce qu'on a senti le ton c'est clair
écoutez monsieur legault a dès jeudi en
conférence de presse occupés et la santé
publique peut proposer ce qu'elle veut
c'est moi le premier est ce que c'est
moi qui peut décider
et il a raison quand il dit ça prouve
qu'il peut à ce moment-là risque est bon
pour tout est bon pour minou 19
premières heures à beauvais ne peut pas
décider que les chefs des partis
d'opposition eux peuvent ne pas être
d'accord avec certaines décisions de la
santé publique c'est pas être contre la
science c'est point de compter vaccins
et là c'est être contre une décision
spécifique est dans une démocratie c'est
quelque chose qui se fait monsieur
legault
des fois on passe et autres décisions de
santé publique
et c'est normal c'est lui qui est
condamnable le docteur ou d'autres ne
l'est pas lui plaide qu'il est allé à
peu près toujours sauf pour la question
des deux mille classes plus s'est
glissée dans la salle de spectacle dans
sa jambe et qu'il a été le spectacle il
dit moi j'ai été plus sévère que la
santé publique jamais - sauf dans le cas
des classes mais chez eux mêmes même si
c'est vrai et seul et sans doute
ça vient d'avoir ça n'interdit pas à
personne de sa d'avoir une autre opinion
que celle de monsieur l'euro et en
particulier l opposition la cci loufoque
honnêtement quand m
martin ça montre que les gens la peau
sensible ça montre que ça fait longtemps
qu'on est là dedans et ça montre que
quand il a dit plus tard dans la
conférence de presse dans un mois ça va
être toute une autre partie notre
réalité
il espère vraiment que ça change parce
qu'ils sentent la pression devient
intenable
la pression et les fautes mais il ya
aussi des devoirs là par exemple le
talon d'achille de toute cette pandémie
là c'était le traçage de dépistage la
l'opération vaccination par quand même
assez lentement nous on vaccine pas à
plein régime encore alors on est obligé
de retenir les chevaux de dire aux gens
mais vous êtes encore sous couvre-feu
vous êtes encore confiné vous pouvez pas
faire du sport à la monsieur legault
commence à 10 mais là
ils ont commencé à vacciner le faudrait
être capable de contrôler un peu plus
cette situation est de permettre
d'ouvrir la machine puis il le dit
monsieur legault changent leur à cette
semaine prochaine très à dernier paraît
compliqué de garder les gens chez eux et
la neige la forme les gens vont avoir le
goût des livres d'or et surtout quand on
annonce à tous les jours des cas qui
sont relativement stables même vers la
baisse encore les gens se disent il va
faire clair presque à 8h faudrait que je
réponds chez mon voyage alors ça existe
cette réalité et ce contexte politique
michel 6 oui et une quelque chose de
lourd comme le couvre-feu il la couvre
feu des avantages et facile à comprendre
tout le monde c'est exactement ça reste
une mesure lourde
ça peut pas durer et est définie main et
c'est pour ça qui est très probable qu'à
la faveur du changement d'heure ou ou
peu après on commence à s'alléger ça à
un moment donné on ne peut pas demander
aux gens de mettre leurs vies au complet
sur pause on peut mettre certains
commerces des choses comme ça on peut
pas faire ça dans la vie au complet et
ça je pense que dans les prochains jours
ou dans les prochaines semaines au pire
on va commencer à voir des allègements
de ce côté là surtout si la situation
sanitaire le permet si ça devait prendre
un mauvais tournoi qu'on se dise les
variantes
ça aussi c'est une autre partie si ça
continue comme cela
oui c'est la grande crainte chaîne avec
que le mauvais tournant dans quelques
jours et on dit que le résultat de la
semaine de relâche dont l'euro dans dix
jours peut-être c'est la crainte et
c'est ça qu'on soit qu'ils n'arrivent
pas en fait
oui bien entendu jusqu'à présent ça va
plutôt bien quand on sauf erreur ou à
montréal et les tests
indiqué que 18 % je pense des côtes sont
des codes de variants par rapport à 50%
et plus en ontario alors jusqu'à présent
ça va très bien on sera évidemment mieux
dans dix jours à peu près mais pour
revenir à monsieur leubou je ne le blâme
pas de vouloir être trop prudents je
pense que c'est lui qui estime en est
responsable et qu'ils seront tenus
responsables si les choses dérapent par
manque de vigilance mais encore une fois
ça empêche pas la critique
voilà la raison quand il fait le
comparatif sur les variants avec
l'ontario depuis deux trois jours en
ontario lonlas la courbe remonte je
pense qu'on n'a pas assez cap des 1000
cole 2000 quelques aujourd'hui alors ça
pourrait nous arriver facilement les
jours puis en france ou si
malheureusement la juge lucie rondeau
qui dit un côté monsieur le ministre
oui je vais continuer malgré ce que vous
me demander d'exiger que certains jugent
dans certains districts soient bilingues
lumineux gelin barrette voulait lui lui
demandait de ne plus exiger ça je
commence avec vous je pense vous l'avez
reçu également votre émission michel c
elle n'était pas contente ballet
diplomatique sont évidemment mais à
d'écouté mal et vous de vos affaires en
un mot c'est aussi proche de soi que le
juge peut le dire en restant poli
oui et c'est le cas dans la séparation
des pouvoirs il ya le principe que les
tribunaux s'occupe de l'organisation des
tribunaux que le gouvernement qui dicte
la cour du québec secours de volume de
comparution si vous êtes arrêté de même
atteint vous savez toutes les chances
d'être le lendemain devant un juge de la
cour du québec et c'est souvent beaucoup
de causes qu'on entend dans la même
journée si l' on arrête parce que il ya
un prévenu qui s'exprime en anglais juge
peut pas on va on va multiplier les
délais judiciaires pour rien et l'autre
chose c'est que monsieur jolie barrette
est dans une situation
est ce son premier ministre qu'il l'a
mis là dans une situation difficile il
responsable de la loi ce de la charte de
la langue française il doit la réforme
et ce sont les ados qui ensuite sont
venues liste émise de justice
on ne met pas en cause la justice dans
cette situation ne s'est pas un conflit
d'intérêts n'est ce qu'un conflit de
juridictions 5,7 ce n'est pas bon
d'avoir amis de la justice qui l'a cette
situation pour voir ce que ça va
michel david que vous en pensez bah moi
je pense que la juge invoque avec raison
ce le droit de gérance je faisais que
lui que lui confère la séparation des
pouvoirs mais aborderait la question
d'autres façons monsieur monsieur jolie
barrette et ministre responsable de la
charte de la langue française
hors la loi sans relâche la langue
française il ya un chapitre le chapitre
iii qui parle de la langue la
législation et de la justice et dans
cette loi dans cet article 2 paragraphe
iv dit très très explicitement que toute
personne a le droit d'utiliser le
français ou l'anglais pour toute affaire
qui est se retrouve devant les tribunaux
alors s'il peut l'utiliser et ça
implique qui peut être compris aussi et
à partir de là à moins que monsieur
jolie barrette nous annonce qui veut
changer cet aspect là de la loi sans la
juger et à 6 je pense sur sur du béton
et il ya aussi dans la même doit selon
l'article 46 qui est sur la langue de
travail qui dit bon la personne ne peut
exiger le la connaissance d'une langue
autre que la langue officielle pour pour
un emploi sauf quand on peut en
déterminer la nécessité etc
et je pense que l'alimentation de la
juge est tout à fait recevable et
convaincant oui martine qu'est ce que
vous avez pensé de cette sortie chassez
d'accord à ce que mes collègues disent
mais je lai a ajouté qu'il faut se
rappeler aussi d'où on vient la
commission bastarache s'est il ya moins
dix ans le presque dix ans où finalement
les juges étaient nommées en fonction de
leur allégeance politique le tout
contribue à la caisse libérale se
pourrait devenir juge
et tout a été changé dans la nomination
des juges pour justement s'assurer d'une
plus grande justice
alors si on commence si les ministres
commencent à s'insérer et ajouter des
règles est-ce qu'on ouvre quelque chose
de nouveau même si
d à la base peut être honorable oui en
tout cas elle lui a dit poliment non
merci
on va continuer à gérer ça à notre façon
merci beaucoup à vous trois très
intéressant à bientôt
au revoir au revoir